Hi, my name is John Travis.
I'm the principal
software engineer
at Hyperic Software.
Um, we are a management
and monitoring company
that specializes
in web-based infrastructure.
Recently, we've got a lot
of requests
to expand our offering
to provide a visibility
to users who are using
the App Engine application
framework.
And cloudstatus.com is the way
that we can give
our users information
about how their application
will perform in App Engine.
Let me show it to you now.
The first thing
when you get to cloudstatus.com
you'll see
is our outage dashboard.
The outage dashboard shows
the most recent seven days'
worth of service health
and some key performance
metrics
across a number
of the web-based services.
In the case of App Engine
we're showing data storage,
delete time,
some read time,
and some memcache access
right on the dashboard.
If there's
any availability problems,
though, these green bars
will turn red
and you'll have more specific
information and links
to form details.
So the four key services
that we're monitoring
for App Engine are
the core engine itself,
the Python runtime,
we're monitoring the datastore,
which is a Python abstraction
on top of the big table access,
memcache service,
and finally,
the URLFetch service,
which shows the performance
and response time
between App Engine,
applications,
and various web service
providers,
including open
social networkers.
So if we dive into the actual
engine-detailed data screen,
we'll see a few things.
The first thing you'll notice
is that this green bar engine
indicates that the service has
been healthy for the past week
and there has been
no service outages.
In addition you'll see
that the Python runtime
has maintained
a pretty constant performance.
So it's about a 1/4
of a second
to calculate
the 27th Fibonacci number.
Moving on, we can take
a look at the datastore.
And how we've monitored this
is decided to create
a typical blog kind of model
where we have a user,
some profile data,
as well as some blog posts.
So what this screen represents
is the amount of time
it takes to perform
various actions
on those models,
such as creating, deleting,
reading.
You can see
that, over the past week,
it's taken longer
and longer
for random reads to occur
in the big table.
This can occur
for a variety of reason,
but it's been fairly constant
ever since we've been
monitoring.
Finally, I'd like to show you
the URLFetch service.
URLFetch is App Engine's
only means of communicating
with external entities.
And this is important
for App Engine developers
who want to integrate
with web services
provided by Paypal, Facebook,
hi5,
any of this open social
networking providers.
The reason this screen
is important
is it shows you
how long it takes
to make web services' requests
to the different providers.
And finally, this page shows
an aggregate across access
that any App Engine user
can expect.
And we provide a plug-in
for Hyperic HQ,
our flagship product,
which allows you
to monitor custom data
that is specific
to your application,
such as how many new users
you've logged in today,
how many dollars you've made,
and those metrics can be trended
and alerted on
with Hyperic HQ.
I learned two great things
when creating
CloudStatus integration
for Google App Engine.
The first was, there's a ton
of documentation out there.
And I would advise
anyone who wants
to write an App Engine
application
to take a look at either
the Google tech talks,
their I/O talks,
or read some
of their White Papers,
such as the GFS
or big table papers
to get an even deeper
understanding
of the infrastructure.
The second thing I learned
was we have to report
a service as available
as available
when it's actually available
and down when it's down.
And this means responding
correctly to service outages,
as well
as scheduled service outages.
To make your application robust
against scheduled maintenance,
simply catch
the capability disabler
and route your users
accordingly.
CloudStatus is gonna be adding
new services
along App Engine.
As soon as App Engine adds them,
you can be sure
that you'll see them soon appear
on cloudstatus.com.